uh welcome back to the last session of
the boot camp
we're super excited to have andrea
uh with two lectures on i think
applications of amp or amp and related
matters
so uh this is the first time
that i won't be bored because i'm
getting a board talk
i'm kidding i wasn't bored at all it was
it's been a great boot camp
okay thanks uh the organizer for putting
this together was a very nice week and
yes many of you are not any more used to
this so you forgive me if i will not be
as polished as
pandemic and not used to this technology
anymore
so okay so i'll talk about two things
two problems the first half is an
estimation problem is actually a
continuation of what cindy has been
talking about in our lectures it's low
rank metric estimation you have a vector
u in
in
rn okay and we think of the norm of us
killing as square root of n and we
observe uu transpose divided by n plus
noise and the noise will be gaussian
with variance of the entries of order 1
over f
and the problem is given the matrix a
this is an n by n
symmetric matrix
i want to estimate the vector u and
and i want to do it efficiently and the
second
question will be an optimization
question
have the same you know gaussian metrics
now i want to
optimize this objective sigma w sigma
and the point is that i will have a
non-convex constraint on sigma and the
constraint that i'll focus on is this
one but
okay presumably the ideas are somewhat
more general
okay and the kind of algorithms that i
look at are
what we called
gfons for generalized first order
methods
and uh okay so
these are algorithms that proceed by two
type of moves okay first of all
i initialize
[Music]
the algorithm with the vector x naught
so whenever as a vector i put the time
index superscript
in r n
and then
alternatively this is alterative
algorithm at time t
i have stored
t vectors x zero or t plus one
x t
so these are vectors
all in a run
and i can do one of two things
i can do
either
either one of two things
to a let's say
is
just apply a
nonlinear function
that acts coordinate twice
okay so here the
convention as you see in this lecture
was that
this is a function from rt plus one to r
and when applied to t plus one vectors
what i mean is that
i put this vector one next to each the
other and then i applied root by row
okay so this is
the matrix x zero
xt this is a
t plus n by t plus one matrix
and i overload the notation by this i
mean that i apply the function and
row wise to to to this to this matrix n
by t plus one
so i can do this d and the other
operation that i can do is uh
i can multiply by a
okay
so these are the two kind of operations
that i want to do and perhaps at the end
of the day i will output an estimate
at time at some time capital t i output
an estimate that is some function
of all my iterates
where again g sum
that applies uh with the same convention
okay so okay perhaps i should start
changing things a little bit
i'll call this actually capital f
so does the definition make sense
so the now this is a definition that i
like because it includes a bunch of
algorithms that we we know for instance
if i do gradient descent
with respect to an objective of the form
xax
plus
plus some phi of x
where phi is separable then it fits into
this this business if you do some
nonlinear power iteration it fits
into this business
some lord
low degree polynomial fit into this in
this framework but not all of them right
so for those of you that are into
low degree polynomials
say just one word low degree because
correspond to low degree polynomials
with
let's say indexed by trees
trees in the complete graph i i can you
know if
you want i can describe this more but
it's not the focus
and okay this this framework is not
completely general in the sense that
this non-linear function
applies row by row
can you know i think it's possible in
principle to generalize to some
non-separable functions but this has not
been done
so let's put me a question that's the
full question okay so this is the
algorithm that
i want to analyze
and uh let me start from a first remark
mark number one
without loss of generality
i can i can eliminate this alternative
and i can decide
and always do
x t plus one
equal
f t of x 0
x t
i should add that that in what i'll do
typically the f are nice functions let's
say that they are lip sheets
although even this is not really
important
oh here of course i did a mistake
because i didn't write anything new
a times f of x d
so i can decide that at each iteration i
apply this nonlinear function and i
multiply by a
and there is not also generating this
because i can always postpone the doing
this stuff right because under anyway
those vectors are stored
so i'm fine
okay so claim number two remark number
two
is that
if you give me
a sequence of function
let's say f hat
t that are always from
let's say rt plus one to r
now you tell me
you know you have to to work with this
kind of iteration
each iteration you don't have a machine
that computes this and multiplied by
matrix a i have a machine that for some
reason computes the function that you
want
multiplies by a
you have an oracle that does this
but then subtract this arrow this is a
known function okay or subtract this
shift
okay i claim the so i claim that if you
give me if you're constrained in this
way i can still simulate any algorithm
of the previous type
namely yeah
if i want to simulate
there is both
like there is a right so
yeah so so this
so suppose that i you know i want to
implement this
and you you build the
machine that the oracle that
says you know compute this and says okay
i i can give you only an oracle that
each time computes the nonlinear
function that you want multiplies by the
n by n matrix but then look it will
subtract the shift
i claim that i don't care about this
shift because at the next iteration i
can
modify my next non-linear function by
adding the shift back
that's that you get to choose little ft
but not that
it's known to you but it's not under
your control it's not under my control
but i can still compensate for it by
adding it back at the next iteration
okay let's see any moment why why why am
i making this remark
i can give you a nasty answer that is
because i'm doing the lectures right
no
no but the reality is that this is a
very good answer because it will be
answered by question because we'll be
answered by
by the next
theorem so
theorem
uh so this is the the amp state
evolution theorem
that that you know cindy gave several
examples of and i will i will
i will give one example that is a
slightly generalization and uh okay so
assume that you have
uh okay you have some convergence on the
spike of your metrics so you have the
spike here and then you have the
initialization somewhere right you have
the initialization right
so i assume that the joint empirical
distributions of the entries of these
two converges
to sound p
u x zero
okay
okay let me call it
z zero from from now on i switch to z
for no special reason
and
i claim that for any sequence
of functions
50
lip sheets
there exists a sequence of function
effect t
such that
the following is true uh setting
or this iteration so that t plus one
equal a
f t
z zero
z t minus effect t
they exist and they are leap sheets and
they are completely explicit but for the
moment it's not important to write them
down
looking at this iteration that i wrote
there then the following happens
we have okay let me write a small
notation
nothing i don't know i don't know
exactly might not it's changed that so i
don't
thank you
so let me let me write it that's and
then
so okay here i'm gonna yeah so this is a
very synthetic notation
to mean that i'll use in the following a
little bit to mean the following that if
i look at the empirical distribution of
the entries of this vector
delta
ui
zero i
the ti
this converges
for instance uh
distribution weekly
to uh
to what to
the law
of u
z zero
z t
okay so this is the type of theorems
that that's in the presented in the last
lecture you look at t iterates of this
algorithm
plus also the spike
you look at you know the joint
distribution so you can put all of these
in an
n
by t plus two metrics and i think of
this as n data points in dimension r to
the t plus two so each this is a row of
this matrix i look at the empirical
distribution of all of these objects so
this is the price distribution that
puts
mass 1 over n on each of this point
i claim that for large n
at any fixed t this converges to a
well-defined limit that is the joint
distribution of this t plus two random
variable
these are capitals so they are random
variables and this t plus two random
variables have the following structure
uh uh used at zero we already know these
are delta
and then z1
the t are very nice
because they are
a vector a deterministic vector
times
u okay u is the random value plus
gaussian noise
okay
and so if i call this g
this g
is normal
zero sigma
okay and so all the distribution is
determined by this
vector and this matrix
and this obey this
so this is independent
of u
z zero
okay and i can you know determine i can
give you equations that determine this
vector and this matrix and the equations
are
like this the equation for mu r
perhaps is clearly if i wrote there
the question for mu is
nu t plus 1 equals
expectation of u
f t
of
z zero
z t
and
sigma t plus one
s plus 1
equal expectation
of f t
of z
0
the t
f s
0
say this
[Music]
okay so
so this theorem is saying and again is
an example of what you know she
described if you look at the row of this
the distribution of the row of this is
completely
asymptotically determined by the
sequence of number mu that give the mean
and the correlation with you and by
matrix sigma and this can be determined
recursively
so perhaps at this point i should stop a
minute and ask if there is any question
yeah so
maybe i'm missing something that there's
only partial information about your goal
is not going to be recovered recovering
you but only like the back of the values
of the entries of you no my goal is
recovering you and this this tells me
the way to recall you for any given
algorithm
i can use for instance z t
result that t is a vector so what this
tells me informally this theorem
that the entry of z t the joint
distribution of the entry of the t and u
these are
yeah so one over n so
let me make it even
more complete
this tells you that one over n sum over
i
one to n of any function psi
of z t i
ui
this converges to the expectation of psi
of
this random variable z t
and the random variable u
okay so in particular you can take any
algorithm of this
form
of this form that i wrote here
okay and you get you know a correlation
between you can compute for instance the
the correlation between this and you
and you can compute the exact limit of
it
yesterday
you anticipated music
sequence and it's a meaningful sequence
uh when
the model is
above the information
for example because you could you could
this applies whether it's above or below
the information
right yeah this is completely general
fact
and if it's below then you get news
which are but so so the question is
at least so the question within this
type of algorithms and
uh within you know by extension by this
reduction within any general first order
method the question is
how should i construct the sequence of
functions of t
now if i construct a1 so the question is
design optimally
so the optimal define of a generalized
first order method
just reduces to the optimal design of
functions f t
as to maximize this this correlation
when the random variables are generated
in this way
and of course i have in mind that always
at the end of the day i can take all of
my values so here i brought the next
method that is just take the last
iterates
but they can compute any
function g
of z i
zero z t
and
y
and this will be
this one would be my estimator
okay so at time t i can accumulate my t
interrelates
apply row wise any function
and so my my real goal is optimally
designing both this function ft and this
final post-processing function g
does that make sense
so in the last
yesterday cindy showed that you know
just to make contact with what she was
doing she was looking at the case in
which this function depends only on the
last difference
and she showed you how to construct the
optimal function in that case
now my goal is a little bit more
ambitious i want to go over all
functions with memory because in this
way i will catch all of this generalized
first order method and my claim is
that actually you went back to this
exactly the same
sequence of function that cindy derived
so
it's uh
like
you could imagine a
first order method of the
generalized first order that doesn't use
the the right sheets but
you say that this would not be
that
it wouldn't be
a good method it doesn't choose the
right that doesn't do these kind of
shifts right so this is only straight
evolution when you're using the right
kind of shifts right but but what i'm
saying is that any other method that
doesn't do this right shift
i can just simulate it by
first running so let's call the
algorithm with the right shift of the a
and p algorithms i claim that any first
order method any gfrm i can simulate it
by running an amt algorithm and then
doing the
post processing and this is just a union
of these two okay
now
if you are speaking you will notice that
really this remark is a little bit
weaker than this because here what i'm
telling is you first tell me effect and
then at the left while here i told you
there is this effect so in principle
this effect and that could be related in
some
nasty way etc but in reality they are
not and this is carried through for
instance in the paper of
with we do china with michael that that
is published and that
that reduction is explained in detail
there
other questions so perhaps an
interesting remark is that this
iteration so there are two iterations
one for the mean and one for the
variance of this the kovari instructions
this zed notice that the one for the
covariance structure has a very nice
interpretation
it tells me that
basically there is an isometry you know
the covariance of the f
is the same as the covariate this is the
covariance of the g's right
sigma is the covariance of the g
so this tells me that okay the f's of
course they are not gaussian in general
the g's are gaussian
but the two are isometric they have the
same scalar products in f2
okay so
it's it's a yeah it might be useful for
you to make sense of this iteration it's
just in the the g are gaussian variables
that have the same covariance structures
as they have
and also if you look at it this this
kind of theorem also tells me that
the distance between this z and this u
there is i mean this variable and these
variables
there is a
correspondence such that you can think
of this basically as the infinite
dimensional version of these iterates
and this is
what i'll do
okay so
now i want to to so so so i claim that i
can reduce always to this thing plus
post-processing now i want to
design those functions
and for that i'll use another claim
yeah this is claim three
and it will be the following
assumed
by this i mean zero i want to stop
writing z zero that one's a two the t i
write z lesser equality
so now we know that in the limits this
is given by sigma
assume that it concentrates i mean
this is not in the object theorem is not
really an assumption but i want to write
this screen more generally
concentrate
around
sigma
ts
again this assumption in reality is
implied by the theorem but i want to
write it as a standalone assumption
and and
and also that lambda of
the mean
of sigma so lambda is equal to a nice
condition number particularly
this is bounded away from zero
yeah so this is deterministic so this is
a strictly positive constant so this
matrix
is invertible then
can reduce
the amp
i can reduce to the case
in which
one will end
let's see one
is
any matrix mst
plus smaller one
uh where am is any positive for any
and that is really positive
here you know i told you this way i told
you come up with
some f's and then you compute sigma
i claim that i can go the other way
around i can determine the covariance
first i can decide any covariance
and then i can come up functions with
determine that covariance and you know
modular changing the post-processing i
will not use anything in accuracy i can
reconstruct all the algorithm that i had
before and the trick is very simple
because
and what's
okay and the the trick is very simple is
simply that since this is invertible
now suppose that you come up with the
sequence of f that don't
don't match the covariance that you want
you can always whiten them you can
always multiply by sigma inverse at one
iteration uh sigma minus one half and
then
multiply by sigma one half at the next
iteration
okay
so i claim that
if you give me uh
this sequence then basically so the
claim is that if you have an algorithm
that
for any algorithm i can achieve the same
performance
by an algorithm that has
a pre-assigned sequence of scalar
products
does that make sense
okay so if that is true then then of
course a convenient choice is that i
will choose this to be the identity
sorry
how does this play with the assumption
that f is separable
well
it's it's okay right because
if i had
right so i have my t
then i multiply by sigma let me call it
sigma so this is now where this is a
matrix that is n
by t plus one
or let me call it
one
and by t
yeah this is it and then
i multiply by this and if i want to
achieve
so so this is this multiplication by
sigma one naught is rho by rho yeah so i
cannot do it in the next iteration
okay
so so i can operate with f that are
orthogonal basically and this is
convenient
because that will mean that this noise
vector is independent of the oceans
okay so under that constraint
my optimization
my algorithm design
question
becomes the following
the algorithm design question comes
simply
say that i want okay let's fix our ideas
and so far i didn't talk about any loss
function that i want to optimize let's
say that we want to estimate u
as to maximize the scalar product
uh what is divided by
normal
okay so let's say that this is our
objective
that i want to optimize well what what
our theory tells us is that for large n
this objective will
converge to this quantity
will be the expectation
of the random variable u
times g
of z
divided by and z here is a vector
the vector until the final time
divided by
[Music]
so i want to maximize this
give two subject to what
two things basically
the first constraint is that
f t of z
place of z
is equal to that that yes
this is the the dirac delta and the
chronic adapter
and and the means
satisfy the iteration that i wrote
before
and that z is of course behind this
and these are simple
so this is now the the algorithm design
problem i want to choose the sequence of
function f and the function g to
recognize this thing
okay now the function g is very easy to
see
to compute what it is it's proportional
to the conditional expectation
given all the rest but okay let me not
compute it
but let me just say that q is an
increasing function
you see observing this thing is
equivalent to now there is an optimal
linear combination of this
t observation independent observation
and the corresponding snr
is
a claim i want to
let's look at the problem you're
optimizing this over g i'm observing i
want to estimate a random variable u and
i observing
i'm observing t independent observation
that are coefficients plus u times noise
well there is an optimal linear
combination of this the optimal linear
combination is
a weighted sum
it's mu i
ici
and the snr of these optional linear
conditions exactly
so because of this water this is
of this what i want really to optimize
so i can forget about this objective i
really want to do i want to optimize
the norm of the vector mu
where mu is determined by the f's to
this recursion
let me write it in an even
more compact way
[Music]
make the solution of this problem more
obvious
i will i can define a random variable
here
that i call fs this is the random
variable that is simply obtained by
applying the function f to that one fs
to the blunt way
so what i want to do i want to maximize
some of the rash less than capital t mu
s square
subject to
and then
okay
that is
and so what i really want to find is a
sequence so i have a sequence of
independent random variables you know
this you know you can think of this as
generating a filtration
fs is sigma
of
z
less than s
so i have a sequence of independent
random variable and i want to construct
random variable f t where f t is
measurable
on
sigma algebra ft
that maximizes this news
i mean
the optimization problem is just the
three lines that you hold at the top
right
yeah the optimization problem
and this defines the muse right this
defines disease in terms of the means
so the optimization problem if you want
is in terms of this random variable f
now in passing from this to this i'm
hiding something that the carpet is that
for my algorithm to work this
object have to be for instance
continuous i cannot take them
while the you know measurable functions
while here i'm hiding that constraint
but okay i can play this game as long as
the end of the day you check that the
optimizer is really given by some
nice continuous function
does it make sense
the point is that after all of these
series of reductions
that
the best generalized linear method
without any of these constraints is no
better than the best thing that you can
get out of this right
and actually i can write this in a in a
geometric way
now this is just a scalar product so let
me write it as a scalar product
okay
so if you write it in this way is
obvious
it's obvious what
it's obvious there is an obvious upper
bound here right first of all okay let
me first write that this
let me
denote u t
e of u given
f t
okay so this is the expectation of you
given the first random variable and here
i can replace this by ut
right
this is this is the first
you can replace well if i have u
let me write it like this
z1
and take first
conditional expectation of u since ft
is measurable with respect to the first
t variable i can take first the
conditional expectation given the first
t variable
and then the expectation
okay so i can replace this by t
and then i'll write this as an l2 scalar
product
okay and now
there is a clear upper bound of ut plus
one
i have a sequence
of orthogonal vectors
and
i'm trying to optimize this
product the orthonormal vector and try
to optimize the last one
times ut
the best that i can do is point in the
direction of ut
when i subtract from ut the projection
on to the first t minus one
so i claim that mu t plus one
is less or equal than what
then the norm of u t
square
minus
the sum over s less than t
fs
dt
square square root
and here okay what is this norm this
normal it's just a nice way you know
this can become
the l2 notation is i think very useful
when you get used to it but
very confusing
this is just this
this is just this
and this is just
ut
would that be the same as expectation of
fsu so that would be just a new asses
yeah okay excellent so not only you're
following me but you're not going ahead
of me
this i can replace by
of f
s u s
because u s is the conditional
expectation of ut given the first test
steps
okay so what did we obtain we obtain the
following beautiful inequality
that mu t plus one
is less or equal than
let's say squared
mu t
naught squared minus sum over s 1 to t
nu s square
and this immediately tells me that for
any t
the sum over
s
one two of t
plus one perhaps
mu s square is less or equal than
ut
okay
and uh
at this point uh we are basically done
because uh so so what does this tell us
i mean so if i if i find
an algorithm that achieves so this is
exactly the quantity that i want to
optimize so the quantity that i want to
optimize is the first sum of the first t
if i find an algorithm that achieved
all of these bounds then i'm done
and the algorithm is clear because the
only thing that you need to do is
saturate each of this you know koshi
schwarz inequality so the algorithm is
just take the iteration to be
basically okay in this notation to be ft
ft needs to be the conditional
expectation of u
given
f t
minus the conditional expectation of u
given f t minus one
and if you now
track what this means this is exactly
the algorithm that cindy described
yesterday this is
simply a function of the last iterates
of the last
zt
what function it is well it's a
conditional expectation of the
distribution of u gaussian noise so in
the end we we find that
the optimal algorithm
is simply
obtained
by taking
the optimal algorithm simply obtaining
by taking ft
of
zero the thinner one has to pay a little
bit of attention because then c0
at a certain point i have hidden things
that zero
doesn't have to be to have this gaussian
behavior so you have to treat it
separate from all the rest but otherwise
you can take this to be the expectation
of
you
given
z0 equals zero
and mu
t u plus g where g is standard normal
equals it
okay okay this is
this is not really important is the
initialization
but basically the optimal thing to to to
do is at each iteration you look at just
the last iteration you treat it as you
treat that t
as
the signal the right signal plus noise
and then you do the optimal basic
denoising procedure
so this gives the
optimal
error estimation error that you can
achieve
by any uh
gf1
uh there are a bunch of reductions that
you've done so this is not the algorithm
that you would use like the optimal
algorithm can be analyzed
the optimal algorithm is this one is
exactly is exactly this one is
yeah this the bunch of reduction shows
that any other algorithm can be seen so
what
let me summarize we showed that any
gfm uh will have the same error
as
one algorithm of this form
plus some very simple post processing
and the very pleasing purpose processing
is form this t plus one by n matrix and
do some nonlinear operation row beta
this by the way is a completely
known asymptotic number you know it's a
completely deterministic claim that
doesn't has anything to do with
probability
hence what we did is that okay so now
all that we have to do is look
among all algorithms to this algorithm
and potentially some post-processing
since we have this theorem analyze the
loss of any of this algorithm
amounts just to
solve this optimization problem
for iteration in one dimensions for
denoising it's some kind of iterative
denoising problem
in one dimension there is standard
denoising where you have a random
variable and you observe the random
variable
plus noise here it's a bit more
difficult because it's iterative so i
have to solve this one
how do i solve this one well
i derived an upper bound and then i
claimed i didn't do the full calculation
but i claimed that this upper bound is
achieved by the algorithm that
and the way i derived to this upper
bound is okay you can work you know with
this cumbersome notation but i think
this is a bit more insightful i thought
of this
iteration as you know a geometric
set of constraints about the iterates
this set of constraints is imposed by my
choice to constrain this to be
orthogonal
and this is just the the dynamics of
this algorithm
and once you have this you have this
upper bound that now erase this upper
bound that is just
basically pythagoras theorem
and crochet farts
and uh and then i claim again that
you know the only way to
achieve this upper bound is that at each
step you know that in this inequality
you saturate cautious parts and
kosciuszvars is saturated by taking the
this conditional expectations
okay so that's
[Music]
so here i could have chosen another loss
function
so i did this for concreteness but let's
say that they choose
another
whatever as some loss function right
maybe they choose e of
uh
for instance i can take l of x y
equal absolute value of x minus y
for absolute value of x once fine
maximum with one so the loss function
that i want to optimize let's say that
is the following
i want to optimize
i want to minimize this loss function
this is an interesting universality kind
of phenomena so i want to minimize this
loss function i describe the maximum but
i want to minimize this okay
well since so this
final process post-processing step is
what
again you know you can there is an
optimal summary of this this is really a
sufficient statistic so it's independent
of the loss and the optimal summary of
this is this one
but i can always assume that you know if
i have this vector of observation i
combine them in this way
this this combination is
some coefficient new sum let's call this
sum square
r square mu bar square
uh u plus mu bar
times g
plus mu bar
times mu bar times g yeah
but it will not change
yeah so so so
you always you
without loss of generality you do this
and then here what you have to choose of
course
is the function g that minimizes this
loss in a problem of estimating of a
one-dimensional random
this is
a small
theoretical statistic exercise to do
but of course this thing is you can view
it as a function of this mu bar it's
always an increasing uh
if it's a loss it's always a decreasing
function it's always a monotone function
of ubar
just by stochastic domination so it's
always important what your object will
always be to maximize mubarak so as boss
said
you know all that you have to do if you
change the losses change the final price
you know post-processing but all the
iterates remain the same
other questions
now there is an obvious weakness to all
of these analysis that this is
you know limited to a constant number of
iterations
possibly to you know some slowly
diverging function of n actually seen as
a result going to
some slowly diverging function of n but
but yeah there is always the mystery of
what happens when you go at a very large
number of iterations but as long as we
are content with these this kind of
within this class of algebra it fixes
the problem here i did the simulation
for this low rank matrix estimation
problem but in the paper with michael we
do it
more generally accepted the proof there
is more complicated and now we have the
simpler
argument that can be taught in
so the issue is the speed of convergence
yeah so so the issue is really yeah
proving this this kind of result now
this kind of result we know that
will not be generally to be beyond
logan iteration so i can give you
examples in which
for instance if i do yeah if i do this
think and initialize with a random
vector
instead with then with something
slightly correlated with the truth if i
initialize with a completely random
vector
this will escape this unstable fixed
point of the log n iterations and is
that moment there is no no rigorous
analysis right
so that
that is a little bit of a case by case
analysis there is probably a simpler
thing that is there to be done that is
look at simpler cases in which you reach
a stable fixed point and you want to
prove that you stay there
actually yeah there is you know some
some some special cases have been done
like that in which you keep iterating
okay so i guess that's a good time to
pause and then during the next
the next hour i'll talk about
optimization i guess
[Applause]
past three